should the west be nervous about
turkey's close ties with russia the two
countries are shoring up their
cooperation as moscow faces isolation
and sanctions
so as it wages war in ukraine how will
russia benefit from the partnership this
is inside story
[Music]
hello welcome to the program i'm kim
vanell russia and turkey are reported to
have agreed on the delivery of a second
batch of s-400 missile defense systems
turkey's decision in 2017 to purchase
the russian air defense system was a
sign of a deepening pragmatic yet
complicated relationship between
presidents foreign erdogan and vladimir
putin but the deal also created a rift
between nato allies turkey and the us
leaving washington to expel turkey from
the f-35 fighter jet program
ankara continues to play what it calls a
balancing act between russia on the one
side and nato on the other but this
doesn't sit well with western countries
they've threatened to impose sanctions
if turkey continues to help russia evade
sanctions over its war on ukraine
well in july ankara brokered a deal
between ukraine and russia to allow
ukrainian grain to be exported through
turkey
but with wheat prices rising because of
the war in ukraine and russia's blockade
of ukrainian black sea ports leading
humanitarian organizations are warning
of a global hunger crisis un secretary
general antonio guterres hailed the deal
as a beacon of hope that would help
avoid food shortages for millions of
people worldwide
turkey lies opposite russia and ukraine
across the black sea and both countries
perceive it as a neutral mediator so
turkey hosted several rounds of talks
with them aimed at halting the war in
ukraine despite nato membership turkey
rejected calls to boycott russia and
instead putin and erdogan say they want
to deepen their ties but turkey also has
a good relationship with ukraine even
supplying turkish-made drones for use in
the war
talks between ukraine and russia have
since stalled
well let's bring in our guests
maximilian hess is a fellow at the
foreign policy research institute and an
expert in eurasian affairs he joins us
from london ludmila samaraskaya is a
specialist in the contemporary history
of the middle east and a research fellow
at the institute of world economy and
international relations she joins us
from moscow sinan ulgan is a former
turkish diplomat and director of edam a
think tank that focuses on turkey's
foreign security economic and digital
policy and he joins us from istanbul
thank you very much uh all of you for
joining us here on inside story i'd like
to begin with you ludmila samarskaya
how have russia and turkey got into this
point of cooperation this point of
closeness
well this all began
approximately
from 2000
so and they've been fortunate like a
strategic pragmatic partnership
um and it was partially based and is it
is still partially based on their
somewhat entire western stands while in
the beginning of the thousands both
russia and turkey they were like
expecting more cooperation from europe
from the the european and western
partners but eventually they did not get
what they wanted turkey did not get
uh it destroyed for
eu
membership
and russia did not get the level of
political cooperation it um
expected
um and so that was one of the basis for
the approach reproachment
um besides they have um
a mixture of overlapping and coinciding
interest in the black sea region and the
eastern mediterranean region and in the
middle east itself
which allows for
um
the cooperation at the same time
maintaining dialogue on the issues in
which they might come be confronted like
for example in 2015 there was a crisis
in their relations when a russian jet
was downed by turkey
but afterwards their relations were
repaired to a certain extent and to date
the economic relations remain very high
and very intensive
they are both one
included in what top 10 partners
uh concerning trade voluntary
and they are cooperating in frames of
the astana farm and they met recently in
the french on this forum in chevron last
month
so they are pursuing this cooperation
despite the differences and the
difficulties that they face at the
moment okay we'll be talking a little
bit later on the show about the economic
ties and how important they are to both
parties i'd like to come to you uh
maximilian hesse in london
how has the previous relationship
between turkey and russia been up until
now because they haven't always seen eye
to eye have they
no uh of course as i was was just being
discussed seven years ago that turkish
and russian relations were at a nadir as
they essentially supported opposite
sides in the conflict in syria and then
we had that incident with the turkish
plane shooting down a russian jet for
straying over its airspace they called
in nato support but didn't get nato to
respond to quite the level that they
wanted to turkish russian races were
really
changed quite markedly however the next
year when the erdogan government all but
accused the united states of being
behind an attempted coup that was what
then led it to make this very large s
400 deal also to agree to deal with
russian nuclear power and to build
further supplies to bring russian gas
and this undermines from europe's point
of view the southern corridor strategy
which was to have turkey be around to
supply gas from azerbaijan and ideally
further afield as well as an alternate
uh to russia now we've seen the turkish
economy in crisis for the last uh year
plus and inflation numbers that make
those in the west uh pale in comparison
um but there seems to be uh no change in
approach as turkey has carved itself out
a rather strategically important region
role in the region and ukraine in
particular of course but also over the
conflict in karabakh between armenia and
azerbaijan and in syria
the west seems to largely be building
its hopes on the idea that erdogan will
lose the election next year so it just
continues to approach it with carrots
and so far we've seen that drive uh
erdogan more into russia's arms i think
he has clear led lines on that he's
opportunistic he's still as you
mentioned selling drones to ukraine i'm
having discussions to broker these grain
shipments out um but so far it seems the
west's approach is is one of uh coming
with uh sticks although
turkey is a nato ally whereas russia's
approach is one of carrots it needs
somewhere to get its sanctioned money
out turkey needs hard currency so it
seems to be a alliance a very
mutual convenience at the moment
in istanbul i want to get your take on
turkey's response to the war in ukraine
kind of generally because as we've said
it's been
towing this line or or managing this
sort of balancing act
yes perhaps the best way to describe to
summarize uh turkey's position
is to state that turkey is being
pro-ukraine without being anti-russia
obviously this is a very difficult
balancing act
but the way that turkey has so far i
think successfully
steered its policy in this direction
was by and this was already alluded to
turkey has continued to supply armed
drones to ukraine which have been quite
instrumental on the battlefield
politically turkey has been critical of
russian aggressiveness
turkey has not recognized the annexation
of crimea so on all those political
grounds uh turkey is on the same page as
its nato allies it has also closed the
turkey straits
to the passage of russian warships at
the same time
turkey is the only nato ally not to have
imposed sanctions on russia the air
corridor remains open
uh erdogan is the only western leader
who has met with putin twice in a month
and there are new agreements that are
being negotiated with russia
so uh this is the difficult balancing
act and uh if you uh basically take a
step back and try to assess what this
has led to
i think this has enabled turkey to play
a particularly instrumental role uh
firstly in the first phase of the
conflict where turkey was a facilitator
for the diplomatic negotiations the two
foreign ministers ukrainian and russian
foreign ministers have met for the first
time in turkey after the onset of the
war then the diplomatic delegations have
also met in turkey of course now the
dynamics of war have superseded the
dynamics of diplomacy but nonetheless
turkey also took an active role and and
succeeded in getting the grain deal
and this is i think important to
underline because at a time when there's
a for understandable reason a very vast
erosion of trust between russia and
ukraine
these countries have actually negotiated
with turkey so the agreement that
enabled the grain deal
were set of bilateral agreements uh
russia and turkey and ukraine and turkey
backed by the u.n so russia and ukraine
between themselves have not uh concluded
an agreement and this in a way
demonstrates the validity of turkey's
careful balancing act towards russia um
cena
before we move on from you i want to ask
you one more question president erdogan
last year correct me if i'm wrong said
turkey was considering
buying more joint well sorry just
considering more joint defense industry
steps with russia including for fighter
jets and for submarines do you see that
going ahead
no i don't
and i think
the news that turkey opted to get the
second batch of s s 400 was essentially
russian disinformation
it is true that
there is an agreement in place
where turkey got the first batch of the
s 400 with an option to buy the second
batch but that option was never
triggered and i don't see that being
triggered under current circumstances
where uh the uh
the relationship between russia and nato
has become
so ambiguous and acrimonious because of
ukraine and also at the time when turkey
is seeking to get u.s support both white
house and congress
in order to modernize its air fleet
and get new f-16s so i don't see that
happening
in in the foreseeable future okay i want
to take that back to ludmila uh
samaraskaya so it was a russian state
news agency that reported that the two
sides had agreed on that second batch of
s 400 air defense systems even if this
is just a talking about an option to buy
the second batch um how is that likely
to go down with nato given the war in
ukraine
uh well that's probably um won't be
greeted by nato countries however uh
turkey also has some issues with our
purchasing systems from the u.s because
the u.s
um
the issues with greece which says uh the
turkey can put it pose a danger to
greece and to brace control over some of
some of the islands there was an issue
where the condition to
not use of the u.s provided
systems against greece and turkey
refused so probably this agreement to
purchase a second part of this as of 100
systems whether it was or whether it was
not it can in any way
you be used as kind of a leverage
probably over some of its nato allies
especially the guys demonstrating that
turkey has options it it's not um
uh it doesn't have to buy the us systems
it can offer to buy something else so
probably it's part of a bargaining act
whether it will be realized or not okay
maximilian hess let's talk about the
economy i believe turkey has been
working with the kremlin on a parallel
import scheme to bypass some western
sanctions um
should turkey be worried about secondary
sanctions or what is sort of turkey's
role in you know russian goods
sure uh you know we have seen turkish
imports in the latest data go up um
quite a bit to russia although that
hasn't uh applied to dual use goods
which are the ones most directly
impacted by sanctions the real impact of
sort of that trade basis is whether
russia is ultimately supplying turkey
with the dollars that because of
sanctions it can't really use and which
turkey really needs or whether they're
trading rubles for lyra which are two
very currently unstable currencies uh
and the lyra experiencing some of the
most significant inflation of any uh
economy in the world over the last year
um so the differences there really
matter if there's any dollar involvement
which is of course actually what turkey
would want more and russia that would
invoke the ire and target of u.s
sanctions but you know to respond to
some of the last points on that as well
i think it's important to understand the
fundamental issues in the u.s turkish
and the western turkish relationship
more broadly aren't issues that emanate
out of uh turkey's relationship with
russia they're stressors and aggregating
fact aggravating factors but erdogan is
really seen as having undermined his
country's democratic project in much of
the west and having used migration and
other tools to try to extract
concessions and before so that
relationship is really broken for
example india which is not a nato member
is also facing many of these questions
buys a lot of russian arm supplies but
also western ones um has been buying uh
russian oil there we've seen the us
congress say that it endorses a waiver
on india's own purchase of s-400s so you
know if the diplomatic relationship
between turkey in particular the united
states and the west could be restored i
think you know the issue of that first s
400 purchase could you know certainly
ultimately be put aside um
but you know it really uh depends uh
what they do and how much they try to
essentially extract the dollars out of
that um sanctions invasion and that
basis and if there's a lot of action
there that washington doesn't like it it
will provoke a very significant risk of
secondary sanctions
cinema president erdogan is facing a
very dire economic situation um talking
about inflation i mean he's also facing
an upcoming election how much is that
factoring into his decision-making
around increasing ties and economic
cooperation potentially with russia
quite a bit
because indeed
the the turkish economy is having a
difficult time not only from the
perspective of macroinstability
rising inflation
but also the depletion of foreign
reserves
which could down the road lead to a
balance of payment crisis so the
government
must at all costs avert this type of
scenario because then you know that
would be uh
basically
it will become impossible for erdogan to
win two elections
if turkey goes through a balance of
payment crisis and this is where russia
comes in
uh turkey is looking to get additional
foreign exchange it's reaching out to a
number of regional countries not just
russia but also the gulf region
but in the case of russia there
certainly has been some movement
with for instance rosa tom
that's the or the investor and the
operator
of the first nuclear power plant that
will become operational in 2023 to be
built on the mediterranean coast uh has
decided to
to basically invest in that project by
way of turkish euro bonds
and this is something that scaled up the
reserves of the turkish central bank so
there are some of these initiatives out
there but certainly
this is very much related to the
economic situation okay which the
government needs to address i just want
to pause you there uh cnn and come over
to maximilian hess who just wanted to
add something go ahead
thank you um you know i think that's
exactly true this balance of payments
crisis and whether it comes before the
election are the you know real questions
that uh turkey faces i think from the
western point of view in particular in
the united states for which you know the
bailout might be the wrong term but
forms of economic support that could
ultimately
alleviate turkey's issues much quicker
swap lines uh for example for the
turkish central bank um into u.s dollars
would not be that costly uh
for the west the question is is are
there concessions the west can give to
turkey on other issues and the antawon
government that it particularly cares
about for the price of making it take an
actual anti-russian posture i think that
would and a basis a conversation on that
basis would uh is kind of enable western
support but so far erdogan has been uh
shopping around the region even
repairing his relations uh with muhammad
bin salman in saudi arabia um
and to get swap lines from from all over
and now this russian investment as well
so i think the conversation needs to be
more on can the west do that as well
budmila samaraskaya we've talked a lot
about how much turkey needs russia uh
due to its uh struggling economy how
much does russia need turkey given its i
guess western isolation
um i think that at the moment turkey has
become even more important partner for
russia than before because
it also is a kind of a bridge
that still connects strategy to the
western world somehow
to a certain extent
and uh it's important for us in the
economy um it's of course not such a
great trading partner is china for
example but it is one of the biggest
ones
still
and it's also one of the ways to
be not hated by sanctions further
and to improve cooperation bilateral
relations and to solve some of the
security related issues and to maintain
dialogue uh considering the middle east
and russians russia's enrollment in
syria for example so it is very
important
uh it's also important for
as being a hub something like a hub for
uh the russians are traveling somewhere
else traveling to europe as it was said
uh its airspace was not closed so yeah
that's really important line uh that's
important line for businesses
uh for us and both for us and turkey and
uh considering uh other issues as well
how much leverage does turkey now hold
do you think with the west i mean
there was the issue of sweden and
finland's admission to nato
um you know uh cooperation on
counter-terrorism
on you know the migrant crisis how much
leverage does turkey hold and how do you
think it might try to use that
well i mean
given turkey's geographical position uh
the fact that it is a nato member uh it
sees its future in the west despite
having you know a number of uh difficult
uh issues both with the united states
and with the eu
gives turkey leverage uh because turkey
is very close to
and this is perhaps unfortunate for
turkey but it's you know it's it's at
the almost at the epicenter of a number
of different crises uh syria
iran uh fight against radicalization uh
refugee issue and so on so relations
with russia
therefore this is the geopolitical
context where turkey's strategic
importance has been heightened if we had
lived in a different world
post 89 where you know democracy would
have flourished everywhere where you
know history would have ended uh perhaps
turkey's your strategic importance would
not have would not have been as high
but today you know we live obviously uh
in a much more difficult world and we've
seen this witness this uh after the 24th
of february uh with the war in ukraine
so in this context uh turkey remains an
important
nato ally despite its difficulties with
its western partners
and we've seen this also very clearly uh
with the uh accession bid of sweden and
finland to nato
where turkey for a while blocked the
start of that procedure
and eventually an mou a tripartite mlu
was signed between turkey sweden uh and
finland to address turkey's concerns
regarding the fight against terrorism
particular pkk terrorism in those
countries okay so turkey is indeed able
to leverage its
its international position and it's your
strategic importance in its relations
with the west okay we're coming to the
nearing the end of the program i'd like
to come back to you maximilian hess
because something we haven't talked
about here which of course is a factor
is the fact that these two leaders these
two presidents are are big personalities
they're strong men they want to at least
project um the the image of being
powerful personas
how has that factored in here when we
look at their relationship and how it's
changing
you know i i think that at least
certainly to some western audience those
uh
terms are you know synonymous uh with
strong men and uh not necessarily
democratic and i think that is really
the perception uh and in many ways the
reality of the turkish regime uh under
erdogan at least this is very strongly
how uh the west feels they uh don't
agree with his hands that they were
behind the the
coup attempt but that's really poisoned
relations ever since and then the
jailing of a lot of deputies from uh
turkey's opposition parties uh in
particular one kurdish party as well hdp
uh has really driven issues and
relations as well as turkey's increased
role in the conflict in libya syria and
elsewhere so
the west really seems to no longer
believe that erdogan is a democrat
there's this famous refrain that he once
made you know democracy as a train um
and you get off at the red point and
this is cited in almost essentially
every major western publication when
they uh write about him but at the same
time the approach to what to do about
turkey seems to be well we're looking at
the polls and he's going to lose the
next election but if one doesn't believe
that erdogan is a democrat then the
question is will he let himself
lose the next election and so far i'm
not sure western policy makers have a
good answer to that all right we're
going to have to leave it there thank
you spasiba to check dededem to all of
our guests uh
maximilian hess ludmila samaraskaya and
cena ulgan and thank you for watching
you can see the program again anytime by
visiting our website aljazeera.com and
for further discussion go to our
facebook page that's facebook.com
forward slash aj inside story you can
also join the conversation on twitter
our handle is at aj inside story from me
kim vanell and the whole team here in
doha bye for now
[Music]
you